una barrera de 40 kilómetros de largo
grecia acaba de finalizar está extensión
de su valla fronteriza con turquía que
además viene acompañada por un sistema
de vigilancia de alta tecnología la
llegada al poder del talibán en
afganistán ha desatado temores de que se
repita una crisis de refugiados como la
vivida en 2015 cuando casi un millón de
personas huyendo los conflictos en el
medio oriente llegaron al país a través
de turquía grecia se rehúsa a hacer de
nuevo la puerta de entrada hacia los
estados más ricos del norte de europa
y aquí crisis la crisis afgana está
creando nuevas configuraciones en el
ámbito geopolítico y al mismo tiempo
está creando nuevos flujos migratorios
se sabe que nosotros como país europeo
participamos en las instituciones de la
unión europea y en este marco una serie
de decisiones se toman pero no podemos
esperar masivamente un posible impacto
turquía es un rival histórico de grecia
ambos países miembros de la otan
mantienen disputas territoriales en el
mediterráneo oriental sin embargo
comparten la preocupación por los flujos
migratorios las autoridades de ankara
también levantaron un muro en su
frontera con irán turquía es el país que
más refugiados alberga en el mundo la
mayoría procedentes de siria
los migrantes irregulares
definitivamente no están permitidos en
nuestra región estamos tomando acciones
legales contra ellos y recientemente
nuestros soldados y policías están
rastreando las casas en las que los
traficantes de personas esconden a los
migrantes irregulares y la mayoría de
estas estructuras están demolidas
mientras las barreras se erigen frente a
los afganos obligados a abandonar sus
hogares la onu estima que 270 mil
personas han sido desplazadas dentro del
país desde enero lo que eleva el número
de desplazados afganos internos y
externos a más de 3,5 millones